hey youtubers is charlie thank you
everybody that's many questions on my
Batman V Superman Suicide Squad video i
meant to post this Q&A yesterday but I
got a surprise lesson and jump starting
my car so they're just gonna roll it
into today I also forgot to mention the
the Vixen show on CW seed they also have
a couple other TV shows they're
syndicating there they're streaming just
like on hulu you can watch the original
flash TV show and terminator sarah
connor chronicles all those are
streaming for free indo you don't have
to pay for the Vixen TV series it's
ad-supported i mean it's just like
youtube but the first big question a lot
of people had a question about the the
jason todd joker theory a lot of people
mentioned the bullet holes on the top of
the robin costume that Batman is staring
at in Batman V Superman trailer and
Joker having similar bullet holes in his
shoulders you have to remember there's
also like a giant bullet hole lower in
the suit and there is no scar in that
corresponding place on joker's body so
like he would have like a giant bullet
hole near his chest as for the grills
Joker is wearing I'm assuming that he
and Batman have been fighting each other
for a long time like suicide squad isn't
going to be the first time that Batman
goes after Joker so at some point he
probably punched the out of his
teeth or it could be like Heath Ledger's
mouth scars like you don't fully
understand what happened to him like
something happened to make him really
messed up looking I was always really
happy that they never fully explained
those Joker scars like every time he
tells a story about his mouth scars in
dark night he tells a different story so
you don't know which one is true I'm a
firm believer that it's a good idea for
movies too not over explain their
villains like they just seem more
terrifying when you don't fully
understand them but there are also a ton
of questions about Robins appearing in
Suicide Squad a Batman V Superman like
if there's a robin costume does that
mean we're gonna see a Robin all say
right now is that just for batman v
superman because that's going to be the
first movie that to come out the movie
will probably show Robin just enough to
explain that suit like if there's a
Robin that died and it feeds into
Batman's storyline of being super pissed
at himself for not being able to save
everyone not being able to save his
family will get like the bare minimum
explainer for Robin really like when
he's looking at that newspaper I think
when it says you know you didn't save
your family it's more a meta
for for the city itself got Gotham the
city the way Zack Snyder explained it in
the movie he puts Gotham on the other
side of a bay from metropolis and
metropolis is kind of like the capital
of the Roman Empire it is height you
know very prosperous city very rich
Gotham is kind of like that same city
after the collapse of the Empire it's
fallen on hard times the city isn't
doing so hot so that kind of feeds into
Batman's paranoia in the movie so Batman
is like the world's most depressed dad
that just feels like he let all of his
children down the next really awesome
questions that a whole bunch of you guys
had is you know what is the DC Cinematic
Universe going to look like after Batman
V Superman in Suicide Squad the short
answer is going to look kind of like the
marvel cinematic universe and that it's
just going to be very big very connected
in case you guys weren't sure they are
going for a DC shared universe so all of
the DC movies that they released in the
next like five six ten billion years
they'll all be connected in the same way
that the Marvel movies are connected but
they are playing with the timeline just
a little bit because Suicide Squad is
supposed to happen sometime before
Batman V Superman David Ayer and zack
snyder weren't on stage together
explaining how both of their movies fit
together like that hasn't happened yet
but the way I heard it at comic-con is
that Suicide Squad is supposed to happen
before the events of Batman V Superman
it's not a direct prequel it just it
just happens sometimes but for it we
don't know exactly when Suicide Squad is
supposed to take place assuming that
Batman V Superman is in 2016 in the DC
Universe but I'm expecting it to happen
you know within like a couple years at
most like it'll probably be relatively
close to the events of Batman V Superman
it won't be like 20 years in the past
that Lamborghini that the Joker's
driving isn't a Lamborghini at all it's
actually an infinity g35 body kit and
that's actually really new they use that
in the movie but until we see more
footage from Suicide Squad it'll be a
little harder to replace it and it'll
probably jump around in time itself too
at first glance it it does sound a
little bit confusing that you're rolling
at this big cinematic connected universe
so logically like each successive movie
would happen right after the events of
the previous movie so why in Suicide
Squad coming out after Batman V Superman
but takes place before it IV it's a
little confusing the short answer would
be is that they want the
Suicide Squad to be a thing in the DC
Cinematic Universe so going into Justice
League like all the movies after Batman
V Superman they want to be able to use
the Suicide Squad characters but they
can't do that till they establish them
so they have to do the origin story
first that's the simplest most practical
explanation whenever they start doing
interviews for the film like whenever
they start like really really marketing
it just expect them to explain that all
the time like each new interview some
will probably ask them about that and
just for reference Batman V Superman is
coming out in March Suicide Squad is
coming out in august I did see a lot of
questions about what's going on with
will smith's Deadshot character in the
movie all say is you know I find it hard
to believe that will Smith would sign on
to a franchise I got really big
franchise that would kill him off in the
very first movie so I'm expecting most
of the biggest actors in Suicide Squad
to be around for a long time they're way
too many characters for people to not
get killed off but just expect like the
biggest most bankable stars to stick
around for a long time you have to
remember that while these movies are
entertainment for us they're like ATM
machines for studios that just spit out
cash so they don't want to chop up the
ATM machine prematurely I did see a lot
of you guys asked questions about like
how many Batman movies they're going to
be what's happening after justice league
especially with the Superman franchise
too we know there's going to be a second
man of steel movie just like a solo
Superman movie but it's not going to
happen for a while the really cool thing
is is that I just heard a rumor that
George Miller of Mad Max fury road is
going to do the second man of steel
movie which just sounds amazing he
actually had a Justice League movie that
he tried to get going a long time ago
that fell apart they're trying to make a
documentary about it right now a lot of
you guys were wondering still you know
about like the Kryptonite Zod twist and
Batman V Superman I don't want to get
too crazy into in destroyers for that
just because a lot of it is theory
crafting right now all I'll say is Henry
Cavill actually did an interview where
he said that the only person who can
beat Superman is Superman himself so
take that really weird metaphor however
you will what I think is happening is is
it Lex Luthor wants to turn Superman
into the villain of his story so he's
going to do whatever he can to turn him
against himself usually what you see in
the comics is like the only way to
really neutralize Superman without like
some some we
deus ex machina comic booky explanation
is to make him doubt himself prevent him
from taking action the problem with that
is that that's not very exciting in a
superhero movie you want to see Superman
fight like some big giant villain so
metallo doomsday weird clone whatever
ends up crawling out of lexcorp's lab I
do think that there will be something
for Superman to punch a lot but for most
of the film I think the Superman is
going to be his own villain you know in
addition obviously Batman's gonna take a
couple swipes at him what I'm really
looking forward to is the Mexican
standoff that the two of them have with
Wonder Woman there's got to be at least
like one brief moment of that they have
to give us that you can't put three
nuclear weapons in a movie without
letting them stand off against each
other for a brief moment that's actually
a really good question now just forget
about the movies for a second and think
about batman superman and wonder woman
if they were all three to try and fight
each other at the same time who do you
think would end up crawling away from
that let's assume that Wonder Woman has
all her gear she has the lasso she has
the sword she has the shield kryptonite
exists and Batman has all of his armor
just looking at things objectively I
think that Batman would probably be the
one to walk away because he's the
smartest just because you have to
remember that the Superman even with all
of his abilities still isn't like a
super genius he's still like a fairly
normal human who's just trying to figure
out how to deal with his powers that's
kind of what his arc is like I'm just a
normal guy from Kansas Wonder Woman is
usually the impulsive warrior so she's
the one that's going to charge in sword
first so Superman is probably going to
be busy dealing with her before he
thinks about Batman Batman has the
Kryptonite ring so really it would be to
his benefit to help Superman defeat
Wonder Woman first then try and defeat
Superman with the Kryptonite ring that's
the dark explanation like the enemy of
my enemy is my friend kind of situation
that's not something that Superman would
think to do first but Batman being
fairly cynical would probably go that
route speaking of which if you aren't
reading justice league right now they're
doing Darkseid war it's this great
storyline Geoff Johns is writing the
anti-monitor vs. dark side that's all
you need to sell it the last really big
question a lot of people are asking you
because of what's going on in the TV
shows right now with their shared
universe that they're creating
especially with like the the justice
league legends of tomorrow show in the
MU
movies you know us getting like a small
Ezra Miller flash tease during comic-con
you know what's going on like how are
the movies in the TV show going to treat
things so here's the deal whenever man
is still came out that was like the
official new beginning of new continuity
so forget about all the other DC movies
that have happened before Batman V
Superman will be like the beginning of
the Batman character in this universe
whatever his story is that's going to be
the new canon yes it will have cameos
from a bunch of other Justice League
people but don't expect them to get
major storylines like a lot of them will
probably just be mentioned in passing
they're just laying the seeds for some
of these other minor superhero
characters so when we get to Justice
League they're already a thing you'll be
able to take your grandparents to these
movies and they'll be able to follow
them like that that's the intention
there's that anybody could walk in off
the street and understand where these
characters come from the TV shows have
the exact same intention and any anybody
can watch them and understand what's
going on but they will be a complete
separate continuity so like when you see
Superman during the Super Girl TV show
it won't be henry cavill's superman none
of the Man of Steel continuity will
figure into that it's like the Justice
League comic that I just recommended if
you read Superman in that comic and then
you read the new Superman solo title or
Action Comics completely different
versions of Superman it can be a little
confusing if you're not used to reading
a bunch of different comic titles it's
just the in dark side wall right now
Superman is still normal Superman with
all his powers but in the new Superman
titles he's been d powered is it's like
two completely separate characters thank
you so much everyone for so many
questions these are always a ton of fun
to do just remind her about fear The
Walking Dead coming this Sunday right
before dares they're doing an hour long
preview of The Walking Dead Season six
so i'll be doing two videos for the
walking dead on sunday night vixen is on
tuesday so be sure to subscribe to get
those videos i'm really excited about
fear the walking dead it's beginning
really good reviews from the critics so
far speaking of really big DC comic book
villains if you guys haven't seen my
Vandal Savage video you can click here I
just talked about his comic book history
and how that shows are going to be
weaving him in
you can click here for my break down to
the flash season 2 footage thank you so
much watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight